thick green algae blankets
frogs
green stained tiles
and mosquito nests
these are just a few things that can be
found inside a pool that's been left to
sit for a few years or even a few days
depending on its location
here's how uk pool engineer miles laflin
better known as the pool guy salvages
these pools by giving them a deep clean
this indoor pool hasn't been used in six
years
plants started growing inside of it
which isn't typical for an indoor pool
mile starts by pumping out the water
nice and empty but not nice and clean
time to get to work
he brushes all the debris into a corner
and disposes of it in a compost heap
the main difference between cleaning
indoor and an outdoor pool is
normally you don't get any sort of
debris in an indoor pool
obviously this one had plants growing in
it took about five five or six years for
this pool to get like that but for an
outdoor pool that'd probably only take
maybe a year year and a half for it to
get like that state
he power washes the walls and the floor
quickly have a guess of what pictures
tiled in on the floor
i went for a dolphin
turns out it's a sea lion that's pretty
cool though
then he uses acid to remove the
remaining stains and lets it sit before
rinsing it away and vacuuming up the
last bits
these are chlorine tablets they're
inserted into a dispenser that slowly
feeds chlorine into the pool
miles adds chlorine granules directly
into the pool for an instant release
this blue liquid is algaecide which
prevents future algae growth
well some people think it's me adding
color to the pool
is that what makes the pool look blue is
what some people
message me
the jelly cubes remove phosphates and
small particles from the pool and
improve chemical efficiency
this makes the water clearer
then he adds salt
it takes a week for the salt to turn
into chlorine through a process called
electrolysis
this was all within
maybe half a day's work
this pool is only gone a few days
without chlorine
it's in a greenhouse so it gets hot
easily
this allows the algae to attach to the
tiles which are actually blue underneath
mild sprays diluted hydrochloric acid
over the tiles
it's just aggressive enough to detach
the algae
when it starts bubbling up it's a good
indication that it's working
then he brushes it in to disturb the
surface of the algae
he hoses off all this and gives it a
good rinse
this only takes about 15 minutes
[Music]
[Music]
this pool has a thick blanket of algae
over it
miles starts pumping out the water with
the submersible pump
then he shovels the algae and debris out
into buckets
algae buildup like this happens after a
pool is left without chlorine
when we had the pool empty we realized
how many frogs there were i'd never seen
so many frogs in a pool before in my
life
like every scoop every shovel fall there
was maybe one or two frogs on on it so
we had to get them out put them on the
side of the pool and let them run off
into the bushes
[Music]
miles applies diluted hydrochloric acid
to break down the remaining bits
get out the old karcher k4
and it's all power washed away
it's all coming up pretty well
he breaks up the hard debris in the
drain with a screwdriver and vacuums it
out
the dirtiest part of the pool is the
filters which catch the debris and
continuously circulate the water to keep
the pool clean
these filters get the job done with sand
so he adds five bags of sand to
replenish them
[Music]
he also adds chlorine and salt directly
into the pool to balance the chemicals
a few bags of salt needed
325 kilo bags
he uses a brush to help dissolve them
into the water
and that's that job done
[Music]
this pool has been sitting for one
summer which is just enough time for
mosquitoes to colonize it
literally so bad i had to like run away
from the pool
the customer has requested for the pool
to be cleaned without emptying it miles
starts by adding chlorine granules
he also shocks the pool which kills off
the algae and contaminants
the process causes all the small debris
particles to clump together and become
heavy
after a few days the debris sinks to the
bottom of the pool and the water is
crystal clear
he vacuums out the debris from the
bottom and finishes by adding more
chlorine
[Music]
you